[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dumais
je dus wenders djouzi bender jeunesse
hub and her shoes du länder bonne humeur
[Musique]
chez moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu m'etonnes sérieuse je serai derrière
comme dans ce n'est pas tout puisque
j'aime ça donne mais fish m'a dit prends
le film ce que j'allais me fais pas
chier c'est fort mais finalement on
s'attache
oui alors un moment les hanouna génial
parce que ces canettes en effet c'est
rare chez les animaux qui est également
faire un peu trop un animal qui ont fait
des bises
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé je vais faire la gorge de la
promo bat pas avec des livres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
justement comme d'une mort
comme je bois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chic et choc donc ça ne sert 2012 un
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ses missions
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
c'était vrai
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là